so first off like to thank Google for
having us throwing this awesome event I
did got to do London when last year it
was a lot of fun and for making a
platform allowing us to do all of this
great stuff and make money which I know
we all like so anyway I'm Jonathan
badeen I'm co-founder and chief strategy
officer served tender I am I guess known
a little bit for making that swipe right
thing so just trying to do better it's
not going to happen probably but today
Jeff and I'd like to share our success
story with going gold our latest
subscription offering and how we got to
that and I think to do that need to kind
of see where we started from
and how we got to that point and and a
way we think about these things so
tinder was launched in 2012 we were
really trying to help people meet people
around them you've got your phone now
everybody's looking down at it at that
time they're not really interacting with
the people around them we wanted to
change that so we launched in 2012
today we're now in a hundred ninety six
countries 1.6 billion swipes per day
that results in about 26 million daily
matches that comes out to over 20
billion matches so far and that comes to
what really matters is 1.5 million dates
a week but to achieve all of that we had
to craft an ecosystem and we looked at
the things that existed prior to us most
of these things came from the desktop
world and we looked at what we felt
could be improved upon in addition to
just doing a mobile first platform so we
had quite a few goals for the for the
platform in the ecosystem but a few of
them stick out specifically for how they
relate to our monetization later on
so we really focused on location it
turns out that locations this pretty
important thing when you're trying to
match two people up to physically meet
in the real world so we focused on that
a lot of the things before us had
allowed the user to search for whatever
or put where they were and all but we
made it required that you use location
services from the app the GPS and all
that was the only way you could do it so
you could only see the people around you
the next is that we had noticed that a
lot of you a lot of people especially
women were getting tons of messages and
it created a lot of noise so you had too
many you got all these messages from
people you didn't want to be interacting
with and then you couldn't find the
people that you were interested in so it
was pretty overwhelming for especially
for women to go through the previous
products the next couple are pretty
crucial we were trying to reduce
feelings of rejection on the on the flip
side this kind of goes actually hand in
hand with the filtering of noisy
messages so you've now got a system
previously where you're sending a whole
bunch of messages hopefully meaningful
and linked lengthy ones to try to stick
out but you had this outbox or this sent
messages list that was basically just
your rejection list so we really were
trying to solve that in an addition is
tube solved that we actually did one
thing to kind of solve both of the both
the the noisiness and the rejection we
added the double opt-in or what we call
the double opt-in so only two people who
swipe right on each other are allowed to
message each other that kept you from
getting unwanted messages and it kept
others from spending too much time on a
single user that they weren't going to
get a response back from to reduce the
feelings of rejection we also did a
couple other things we
he decided you can't go back you can't
sort of dwell on a user there's once you
see them they're gone because it's kind
of hard to feel rejected by somebody you
can't remember alcohol works too so we
also wanted it to be anonymous you don't
feel quite as rejected if you if the
other person doesn't know that you're
out there it's the worst thing is
putting yourself out there and then say
hearing no so nobody would know whether
you liked them or not unless they at all
right unless they also like you the last
thing we did was we tried to create
something that was fun and simple that
comes through and the the lightweight
the game-like interactions the swipe
itself and this sort of gets us to the
point where about two years after
launching we're now trying to figure out
how are we gonna make money off this
thing costing us a lot of money run this
and we started to think of how we wanted
to do that and we decided that we wanted
to accomplish this by adjusting the we
needed to adjust some of the rules of
the games which of the game which we
felt we'd learned from from some unseen
unforeseen behaviors but we also wanted
to perhaps let people break our initial
rules so in 2015 we launched tender plus
we did we launched it with three
different features and we did price
testing which showed us that we would
start out with a $9.99 price point those
features included passport passport
allowed us and allowed you to break the
location rule and the and so you didn't
have to go off the GPS and you could
virtually travel anywhere in the world
then we also had rewind which allowed
you to go back spend a little bit more
time maybe change your mind on whether
which way you swiped for somebody now
the next feature paired with was paired
with a change to the overall game
we hadn't really expected this when we
created tender what weather with your
finger or a piece of meat what you're
really doing is creating a lot of noise
one of the things that we were really
trying to get away from you didn't have
these earnest matches and so what we
decided to do was to limit the number of
match number of swipes right swipes that
you could do per day to hopefully make
people think a little bit more about
their choices but because we like money
and because we thought maybe there are
reasons for you to be able to to have a
little bit more we gave you unlimited
right swipes and this concludes the
first feature set that we had launched
but as time went on we added a few more
that included super like and boost super
like allows you to sort of break the
anonymity rule it would allow you to
express interest in somebody which in
turn actually I guess maybe displays
confidence or and makes it more likely
that that person is going to swipe right
on you them knowing that you already
liked them and then we gave boost which
basically everybody has to stand in line
it's only fair but boost allows you to
cut in line a little bit for a temporary
amount of time we also added a slew of
other features I won't really go into
them but what I think the real point
here is is we had a whole bunch of
features and our price point stayed the
same so we're giving you that much more
value than we originally did with tender
plus so now that you kind of know where
how we got to all of this and and where
we were at this point how it ties into
our ecosystem to the point of before
making gold I think it's time for Jeff
to share with us how we went about doing
that sure thank you guys thanks to the
Google team I had the pleasure of
traveling to Asia last last year with
with a bunch of you guys so really nice
to be here again
so Jonathan just went through how he
created sinner and I'm gonna I'm gonna
show you how I broke tinder because
that's what I do
but I'm Jeff Morris I'm the director of
product and revenue responsible for
tinder gold and also built Bruce and a
few other things so this is this is the
team I work with it's about 18 people
I'm showing you this slide just so you
know to build kind of a global business
you don't need this massive team so if
you're sitting in your office thinking
you know that's great that tinder did
that but I probably can't do that you
you can you just need the right kind of
the right roadmap instead of ideas so as
mentioned Jonathan just showed you all
the other rules that he created my job
when I walk in the office every morning
is to think of what rules we can break
and and what features we can give some
subset of customers but not everybody
because it would literally break the
game of tinder so if you think of Bruce
as an example if everyone was boosting
at the same time the whole world would
be boosting and the game would just
break and so I'm thinking of things that
we can give people and limited cohorts
that that will make the game more
efficient or fun and the key thing here
is if you if you think that any rule
that you build in your products so all
those rules that Jonathan does should
you if you think those are sacred and
you walk into work of it and you're like
you know we could never do that your job
is to is to challenge that so go to work
every day think of what's what's in your
game your application that you can you
can unlock for a certain subset subset
of people so if there's any two things
to take away today it's it's these two
it's this is how I think about
monetization its access and exposure and
you can read all sorts of books on game
theory and how you how you design games
but if you just have those two things in
mind you can probably go to work and
come up with some pretty cool ideas a
lot of what we do and and this is this
is a newspaper article from the 1800s I
show you this because you don't always
need an event something new what you can
do is make it a lot better
so this is this is a a male paid 25
cents for this which is four dollars and
fifty cents now he took out an odd scene
he's an honourable gentleman waiting for
the right woman tinder is obviously a
lot more efficient but you know we're
not always inventing new things and if
you if you look at some of the features
we built you can probably find something
historically that did something similar
but our jobs to make them kind of 10x
better and so speaking of history this
this is what we built last year 2017
it's a feature called likes you which we
package within tinder gold and I'm going
to show you kind of the crazy
development I've never shared this
actually so we'll see how it goes well
show you the development process that
went into this we made some some really
bad decisions and some good decisions
but ultimately really happy where we
landed so so I'm gonna and feel free to
make noise if you think this is a good
idea bad idea but this was the first
version of likes you which was the main
feature so I broke one one of Jonathan's
rules which was I want to show you who
likes you before you swipe we kept the
double opt-in so you both need to like
each other to message but I really
thought that the game could be more
efficient if I just knew who liked me
and so and so ignore these prices by the
way this is a designer who clearly
doesn't know how to how to price things
it's our average price was anywhere from
$9.99 to 1999 we had this very dense
feature set so you saw that lists of
items probably ten features that we had
already packaged within tener Plus and
kind of the debate we had on the product
team was we're unlocking what's probably
the most valuable thing we could ever
give away on tinder which is showing you
who likes you and now we're just gonna
give it to everyone within tener Plus
that didn't seem like a good idea and so
we went back and forth and this was the
original design again we were gonna
package it within tender plus and so one
day one of us came to work actually were
text messaging and we said what if we
just allowed people to have multiple
subscriptions
you could literally have two different
you can have tender plus and tender gold
at the same time which we had seen games
do and it seemed like a really cool idea
and then I met with our finance team in
our accounting team and they thought it
was a terrible idea
and then we just talked more about the
customer journey and what it might feel
like to have two different tiers at the
same time that would get pretty
confusing we have seen games do this and
it's kind of a cool model which I could
see becoming a thing one day but but not
quite yet and then v3 where we landed on
which I'm really happy we discovered has
a simpler version so as a tinder plus
upgrade which is now we create tinder
gold one key thing is is we spent a lot
of time on the branding so we didn't
just want to call this like tinder plus
plus we we thought about what's actually
cool fun what's gonna get people's
attention so one of the things which we
didn't show here is when you when you
tilt the phone the gold kind of tilts
with you and it has a shiny animation
effect all of our pea wolves have like
crazy animations and fun things probably
inspired by people like Jonathan who are
kind of product perfectionists
/ nerds oh sorry Jonathan who you know
we spend a lot of time making our
paywalls better which seems crazy but we
kind of we geek out on that stuff as
much as we do the core product but
basically what you're seeing here is is
this is the upgrade below so as you see
here you can upgrade for $9.99 a month
we still feel like so at $19.99 you're
basically paying $29.99 a month if
you're if you're on the $9.99 tier
you're paying $14.99 we still felt like
that was probably low but we thought
$9.99 felt like a good place to start
and one of one of our concerns was I'm
sure you're sitting here saying you read
articles about different people raising
their prices and customers revolt and we
definitely had that fear you know what
what customers think this is fair I'm
paying for tender plus now after to
upgrade would they think it's too
expensive would they find enough value
in one feature to justify an upgrade
and we definitely were worried about all
these questions ultimately we we solved
everything through testing so you know
our older cohorts showed us that they
were willing to upgrade and we proved
that through a very limited tests but if
you're if you're kind of scared about
customers revolting like definitely a
great concern but I would challenge you
to to run tests to see if that's the
truth also we have as was mentioned we
have a shorter kind of life cycle so we
have cohorts coming in and out so
there's no like hopefully there aren't
people have been on tinder for like five
years who are sitting at home really
upset about this because we have new
customers coming in every day and people
leaving because hopefully they found
something that they really like I'll
just show you a breakdown this isn't
anything that appears in the application
but if you really look at what we did we
created a new tier off of one feature so
if you have one thing you're thinking
about unlocking you can you can possibly
create a new tier just off one feature
this would be a very boring thing to see
in the optic kind of looks like a SAS
billing page but but you know the key
thing to see here is we have this rich
feature set which is tender plus and we
just tweaked it a little bit and create
tinder golden one of the challenges
we've run into and we're still figuring
out is how do you how do you sell
multiple tiers and so we have this this
baby we created it's tinder plus
business is going really well stock
price is doing well like the company is
really comfortable and happy and now
we're gonna release gender gold so how
do we sell two things at once within
this small real estate that's your
mobile phone ultimately we we were very
conservative actually so we probably
have dozens of entry points to pay walls
within our app but we really only sold
two nor gold from two places one being
your your matchless which we had never
monetize before so if you tap on that
that ten says this person has ten plus
people who like them or you can use your
settings page and we we started to
tinder gold more than tinder Plus again
people who worked on tinder plus it's
kind of like telling them like their
babies no longer like the focus of our
attention we're not moving on but we're
we're willing to try something new and
focus on something new and that was
definitely a concern internally but
again we tested also certain cohorts we
emphasized tinder gold to more than
others so if there are price sensitive
customers maybe you do wants it to get
them hooked on the kind of the intro
package again you'll have to test this a
lot but merchandising definitely becomes
a challenge only recently so we're about
a year into - tinder gold we're just
starting so if you think of the game pad
on tinder you know things like rewind
things like running of likes
we weren't even letting you subscribe to
tinder gold until about a week ago
from those paywalls and the big concern
there is what if you just what if
conversion flops from your main pay
walls and then you're suddenly in a
world where we're trying to kind of like
revert back to your old model we also
considered a tabbed version again like
that sass page that I showed you we
don't want our pay walls to start
feeling like there are so many different
choices that I have to make so right now
we have a single and three point option
which is you can only buy tinder gold
from our core paywalls one cool thing
that we saw I think for any revenue
feature you build you want to build
complimentary features so you know
rather than having things that that
cannibalize other paid features we made
boost more valuable as an example so
here's a user who's sitting there likes
lists Bluestein and they're collecting
more likes kind of in real time so a
very powerful kind of way to augment
what was already a great feature with
boosts so just as you're building new
features think about how they'll
interact with your other paid features
and if you're designing a game or
anything that's social hopefully they'll
make that feature better here's the
results so proud to say we were number
one in Google Play last year I'm not
sure where we finished this is January
we finished the year number two behind
that flicks for non gaming apps you know
this was all kind of there were many
many ways we got here but but the goo
the tinder gold tweak was was what
really kind of pushed us over the top
we nearly doubled subscribers more than
doubled our revenue 3.1 million average
subs which was an increase of 544 K and
then again second second highest group
Christine app this is kind of the hockey
stick that we like to see again I'm not
gonna give tinder gold all the credit in
the world because other people match
group might be here a might beat me up
in the alley afterwards but but again we
saw this this great result in the public
markets which was our stock price more
than doubled and again there were many
many ways we got here but but we we were
happy this happened one other result
we're always searching for features at
tinder that will appeal to women
subscribers the honest truth is in the
dating space men are far more likely to
pay for for features than women
it's it's just how the how our vertical
happens to work we did see and here's
this was actually a tweet yesterday it
said a few people couldn't attract
tender gold and honestly the quality of
my conversations and dates went up a lot
we did see an increase for female subs
of 7.4 percent when we released gender
gold which were really excited about
GQ said this was it's more lady friendly
which is good news for everyone
I'm not sure what's going on here but
but we were happy about this article so
so if I want to leave you with any rule
it's go back to your office after today
go to people like Jonathan and say that
you want to break your own rules that's
how you monetize and yeah go forth
you